i believe that there are millions of  kids under the age of 18 making six  figures on social media and youtube  while everyone's focused right now on  the potential or the act of great  resignation what none of them are ready  for is the great never applied in the  first place humans have options in a way  that we and our parents and our great  parents never imagined the internet and  the emergence of the consumer blockchain  is creating viable options for the 50 of  people who are creative that is a  profound  situation you have an entire generation  that is barely holding on to consider  college and definitely not considering  taking a [ __ ] job that they don't  like for 53k 60k 70k they rather live  with each other and get by those early  years because it's logical  [Music]